Một một tháng người, trong ngân hộ lễ thiệt thành niên Việt Nam, phối hợp cùng có TTCP Việt Nam,
tổ chứ các loa thành niên sống đẹp năm 2018.
Nhanh Tôn Vinh 20 mật trẻ thư biểu đã có hình độc đẹp,
nghĩa cử nhiên văn và đón có tích cửch cho sả hội,
là nạn mẹ tinh thần sống đẹp,
súng có ích trong cộng đồng thành niên Việt Nam.
Dà đời tự năm 2018, đại tưởng thành niên sống đẹp,
nhằm tôn Vinh những thành niên thư biểu, những người có hình độc,
nghĩa cửch nhiên ai, măng tình thương thân tương ai,
có bình lăn tòa những giá trị nhân văn trọng sả hội.
Năm nay, chương trình tôn Vinh 20 mật tổng thư biểu,
hai mấy câu chuyện đẹp về nghiệp lực,
nhân ai và khát bọng sống đẹp dễn cho hàng trưởng thành niên Việt Nam sống đẹp,
súng có ích sống việc cộng đồng.
Chồng số đó, có nhiều câu chuyện súc đồng,
là tòa mạnh mẽ, cà sĩ hoa mình gì,
là hình bóu của một việc sĩ sống đẹp,
gắn bỏ với cộng đồng và lắng tòa sả trị nhân ai,
trường văn mộ á thiệt, sả xong tình Việt biên người đã súng cảm quên mình vì cộng đồng.
Thì phát hiện giấu hiệu bất thường vào hiệu quyết cơ lũ quét
và sạch lợi đất miếm trọng tại bản hàng U.C.
Và họ mỗi tâm hương được tinh sang là một câu chuyện đẹp,
một hạt mầm tốt lành, đang âm thầm xe niềm tin và lắng tòa tình người
góc phần xí dựng mùa sả hội nhân văn văn mình và phát triển bệnh vũ.